and i'm from the design singapore
council
i'll be your event mc and the moderator
for today
thank you for taking your time to join
in this webinar understanding
internationalization
the session is brought to you by design
singapore council the national agency
for design in singapore
and is supported by aspire research and
consulting
before we proceed i would like to
highlight a few housekeeping rules
should you encounter any technical
issues
please reach out to our technical team
through the zoom chat function
we ask for your patience and
understanding should conditions be less
than perfect
during this webinar your audio will be
on mute however we welcome
questions throughout the zoom q a
function
when posting a question please state
your name and your company
now please allow me to introduce our
speaker today
janet singh deputy ceo spire research
and consulting
who will be sharing more about the
benefits of expanding into a new market
and how companies should go about
through the process
so without further ado i'll hand you
over to japaneet who'll share more about
it
so check it please thank you gaia
good afternoon everybody let me just
share my screen very quickly
okay um once again good afternoon
everybody
um my name is jeff neet i
represent a company called spire
research and consulting
i was approached by dsg to really talk
about
um what are some of the opportunities
that exist
right now across southeast asia region
which is really a focus
of my firm i'll i'll talk about that in
just a minute
to give you my personal background
i have been in the research and
consulting industry
working with mostly large multinational
organizations as well as mid-size firms
and helping them grow in the southeast
asia region
along with my team here at spire but
interestingly
i previously come from the design
industry as well i used to be an
architect
i worked as an architect i'm trained as
an architect and i worked as an
architect for about
uh three three years in india which is
where i come from
and then i moved to the southeast asia
region
and really sort of shifted more into a
business angle
okay so um what are we going to be
talking about
today uh i'll start off and
i'll talk a little bit about uh the
introduction
um and then we'll go into each of the
countries
a little bit in depth and i wanted to
share some numbers with you really
um you know that will paint a fairly
good picture of
uh what's happening in these
organizations in in these markets
um i then want to just quickly
talk about some of the opportunities
that are available for singapore
companies
in terms of grants and growth
opportunities
and then we'll close off with a case
study where
i'd like to tell you a story about how
my organizations help the design
firm expand overseas
okay so um spire as i mentioned
is primarily a market research or a
research-based consulting
company we help our clients
most of which are multinational
organizations mid-sized
companies as well as government
organizations
we we basically help them assess the
external environment
that they operate in identify
opportunities for them
and then help them grow and expand uh
into
primarily asia uh but a lot of the focus
of that is in
southeast asia region
in terms of uh maybe i'll quickly just
rattle off some of the services that we
offer
so market research is really the core of
our business we also provide
internationalization support
feasibility studies and we help bring
companies together with potential
partners
okay so as i mentioned um
our focus primarily is asia and you will
see
in this map um where sort of spire
operates
so along with our group we cover pretty
much
all of the markets all the attractive
markets at least
in southeast asia region india china
korea japan taiwan as well
okay so um we have had the opportunity
to work with
really cutting-edge leading
organizations across sectors
so as you can see from this slide here
um you know a lot of the work that we've
done
is with um really the
the industry leaders uh and very large
sophisticated organizations
so we've really had the opportunity to
learn from them
as we provide them with insights as well
and you know i'm i'm happy to
share some of those insights and some of
those trends that these companies are
seeing as we work with them
okay so um let me start off
with the question on why to expand
now singapore is a very vibrant economy
uh
and a very vibrant market but it is
still rather small in terms of just
population base
we're talking about less than one
percent of asean's total population
uh being in singapore
despite the relatively high purchasing
power
even apples to apples singapore is
relatively
a small market so companies that
are seeking to grow will
sooner or later hit the boundaries of
the market
and which is why it's very important for
singapore companies
to start looking at the asean market
where you know there's very little uh
trades in and
duties and things like that uh really to
start looking at that as a region
as your playing ground now the main
motivation for
why companies expand and you know this
is from the eiu
survey that you're seeing the biggest
reason of course as i mentioned
is opening up of new markets for their
products and services
gaining market share is also one thing
that is
is an important uh reason uh
as well um the third reason i think is
something that
you know singaporean companies can also
relate to which is just an increase in
pop
in competition and a slowing down of
demand
domestically uh cost effective
production
cost effective or just lowering costs in
terms of supplier costs or
labor costs and finding new talents
i mean this is something that i think
has become increasingly important and is
very very specific to
singapore you know in the last
year or so we have seen a talent crunch
that's happening
in singapore across various sectors and
if the talent can't come to the
companies then maybe it's time for the
companies to start going to where where
the talent is
and we've seen this migration with some
of the design companies
uh as well where you know they've
shifted a lot of their base
to overseas to their overseas offices
and have started to cater to the
regional clients
from a more regional sort of a setup and
then you know there are various other
uh reasons as well r d um acquiring
brands
uh you know and then sort of gaining
access to new materials or
like like i mentioned new technology as
well
okay so um the last year has been rough
and it's
not just for for singapore i think it's
been rough in general but to talk about
singapore
um specifically uh
according to uh an sg enterprise survey
there was a dip in the number of
companies that actually went overseas
quite a significant dip but it didn't go
to zero you know so
38 lesser companies than 2019
ventured outside having said that
a survey also says that in the next
three to five years
87 percent of singaporean businesses
surveyed
will be looking at expanding uh overseas
uh for the companies that are already
existing or have already expanded in the
region
we did see a contraction uh with a
fairly large percentage
so 47 said that their business overseas
has
also slowed down um but
you know all more than half uh or a
little bit more than half
said that their their business has
either been stable
or has continued to grow so
internationalization and expanding into
markets is also a way of hedging your
risks
um in in you know times
when there is an economic downturn when
there's a downturn in
in demand
we see the utilization of digital
platforms
becoming increasingly important so as
travel restrictions come in
virtual trade fairs or business matching
events
as well as e-commerce platforms have
become increasingly
important challenges still remain
i think um you know
being able to physically expand of
course is a challenge
but also there's a lot of pressure on
cash and cash flow that's coming in
in the last uh one year or so um
but almost all companies that we have
spoken with
uh in singapore and across the region
technology has been the way that they've
been able to
adapt to to to this and you know we're
quite pleasantly surprised that the
technology gap that used to
exist between singaporean companies and
say companies in vietnam
uh has to a very large extent closed and
narrower and these companies have
adopted digital means
in a very very successful way
okay so um
let's talk a little bit about what are
the options that companies have
when uh they're considering entering
into a new market
uh the first one really is is
sort of plain and simple um exporting of
services or exporting of products
from the home country to these
opportunistic
markets the second one takes the the
relationship a little bit more in depth
so that's when there's licensing sharing
of technology sharing of brands
um you know and that sort of falls under
licensing and
franchising and this has been in the
past a very successful way that
singaporean companies have moved into
malaysia uh indonesia thailand
uh the third area is strategic alliances
and partnerships and you know these
could be joint ventures but in a lot of
cases they are
you know not as involved as joint
ventures
but their strategic partnerships of
conducting projects together or
conducting certain business activities
together the fourth area of course is
acquisitions in
m a is something that our parent company
uh does quite a bit in bringing uh
japanese investors into the region
um but this is when really you know
you're talking about equity
uh ownership and and changing or
participating
in a more meaningful way and in a more
involved way with
uh the companies that are already
present
in these markets and of course the third
or the last one there
is starting from scratch so greenfield
ventures which basically is
you know going at it pretty much on your
own
and really growing organically within
these markets now
there are advantages and disadvantages
to uh all of these
uh so if we start off with exporting
it's relatively easy to do let
low risk but the degree of control that
a company has
in that market is very very limited uh
one of the challenges about using
exporting to grow
on a more sustainable basis is
really the inability to control the
price at which your product gets offered
so
you know singapore compared to some of
compared to
the countries in the region is
more of a high cost uh producer
uh both for good sensor and services so
being cost competitive when you're
directly exporting
not being able to tap into the low cost
advantages of these markets
uh you know puts a lot of pressure on
price really and
it's difficult to be price competitive
um
licensing and fraud challenging sort of
takes exporting to a more
long-term uh sort of a perspective
so you know the costs can can come down
a little bit
because some of the processing or some
of the work can happen
overseas but also relatively
quick to enter and quick to scale up uh
in the market if you're going down the
licensing and franchising way
partnering in strategic alliance is it's
rather wide and really depends from
company to company
but you know costs get shared that's a
that's
uh an advantage um some of the risk gets
shared and you're able to bring in local
expertise which is incredibly important
in all of these markets um
but also you know it there is
some amount of capital investment
involved depending on on how you're
doing it
and of course there is a risk of ip uh
you know being misappropriately or or
inappropriately being used and that
i think remains a challenge because
while all of these countries do have
fairly good iep
laws the implementation is quite weak so
that
is always the risk
acquisition can be quick and sudden it
can take some time to find
the right partners and of course it's
a much higher risk and it requires you
know
capital expenditure to happen uh up
front
but the level of control that you're
able to get is
a lot higher so you know that's sort of
the the advantage
and you're able to hit the ground
running um
being able to control and capitalize on
the local
talent and the local strengths of the
organization
and then the last one there of course is
greenfield so in terms of risk i would
rank this
maybe slightly above uh exporting
uh as a mode of entry um
but it is a much more slow and a much
more tedious process and given the covet
environment i think
you know this particular process has
become even slower because
it's more it's become more difficult to
travel to the neighboring countries
um having said that it is it is a more
measured way
of uh entering the market and you can
pace this
depending on your company's capabilities
as well
okay so before you start
considering expansion expanding overseas
you know we would like to share really
these three very critical steps
that need to happen uh please consider
these as a checklist
uh we have seen companies that
you know have seen an opportunity are
quick to rush in but
they're unable to sustain that growth in
that momentum
in a lot of the markets so really then
you're just
you're adding on cost and you're adding
on risk
so the you know these three steps are
very very important
the first one being um
really understanding the market that
you're getting into and
assessing the match between your company
capabilities
and the target markets
this really means assessing whether
there is a demand for your products
it also means understanding the local
workforce or the local infrastructure
that's going to be available
because on a sustained basis you do want
to be able to enter the market and use
the local
resources there and of course
local laws and local regulations can be
quite different from
singapore so having a very good
understanding of
what the company would be able to do and
not do i think is
is very very important
step two really is market immersion um
about well in 2019 this was the
relatively easier part
and it basically involved traveling to
the market
um it's become a little bit more
challenging
uh you know to do on a virtual basis but
it is something that's that's
now become the new way uh we are
seeing a lot of business matching events
a lot of webinars and that
is well it's not a perfect substitute
but it is a fairly good substitute for
you to immerse in the market
um trying out pilot projects is another
thing that we're seeing a lot of
companies
do as well and you're able to confirm
the data that you're seeing from your
research
which basically happens in step one
and then step three of course before
really setting up
doing the administrative uh steps
and setting up presence is to have an
established network
of of partners some of this happens in
step two
as well across the southeast asia region
we see the need for local networks and
local presence is
very very important in fact it becomes
the critical success
factor in many cases so
establishing those contacts before you
go
and and enter into the market and start
taking on risks
from that market uh it's very important
to have those connections there
you know and you know so it helps you
address the work cultures and the
language barriers and
all of those as well
so we'll talk a little bit more about uh
these steps so step one this is where
you as a company would basically need to
do market research
um a lot of this market research
would revolve around customers
identifying
what the profile is who you're going to
be selling to who's going to be
receptive to your product
and their willingness to pay the price
that
you're expecting to charge um you know
having that done
adequately can mitigate a lot of the
pain
and a lot of the adapt adapting that you
have to do
later on as you go into the market the
second area there of course is looking
at the competitor landscape and you know
there is some basic research that you
could do to figure out who are the other
players
but it's very important to to map out
the competitive matrix and what that
really means
is to map out what positioning
the other established companies have in
in this market that you're about to
enter into
and figuring out where you'd be able to
differentiate
and if you don't see an opportunity for
you to differentiate you know then then
you're basically competing on price
and that can be challenging for a
company with
costs in singapore
so understanding the competitor and
understanding the customers
is is very very critical and that really
points to you
on what the business plan and what the
offering
needs to be it also helps in many cases
to convince senior management uh or
your your uh you know your fund
providers
uh on your plans and to get that support
uh once you've understood the
environment that you're going to be
offering that you're going to be
operating in
it's really also good to understand the
resources that you will have
so the workforce is something that that
needs to be looked at things like
salaries also in terms of regulations
and that's really
point c um one of the critical things
that companies also assess is how easy
is it to exit
from the market and you want to be aware
of that
um in countries like vietnam and
indonesia
exiting can be a challenge and can be
rather expensive
as well or scaling down can can be
something that's that's very
uh tedious uh so
in an environment in this rather
unpredictable
unpredictable world it's important to
have that knowledge
as you go into the market as well
okay so step two we were talking about
immersion
there there are as i mentioned uh a lot
of local events and a lot of webinars so
tuning into these
i think becomes very very important um
you may or may not find that some of
these are rather basic but they still
provide
a very important avenue for you to
network
with other companies
in most of the countries there are trade
associations
that focus on developing the creative
industry
or certain industry groups as well so
it's very important to tap into those
uh you know and actually here at spire
we do a lot of business matching events
or virtual events
uh and you know we're happy to talk to
you about more about those or invite you
for those
uh as well you know and really what
immersion does
is not only start to build the
connections that are very critical
in step three uh but also helps you get
a more intuitive sort of a sense
of the market apart from it really what
the data is telling you and what the
consultant wants to tell you
okay and then of course we have step
three which
is really finding the right partners
that can open the doors
um we have found that in southeast asia
you know while while
singapore and you know a lot of the
overseas
or i'm going to say companies that are
in more developed markets
there is a very strong brand affinity
for these countries but
most customers still prefer to deal with
somebody local
and you know we see this in indonesia
where
while most people claim to speak english
they much rather do business
in in bahasa in thailand of course
there's a very explicit language barrier
um
so having local people there is
quite critical um or at least having
local partners that can open up the
markets for you they can open up the
doors
uh has is is still very very critical
okay so what i want to do in
the next section is really share
um some numbers with you about
some of the southeast asian region uh
markets and
really talk to you about what are some
of the opportunities and some of the
risks that we're seeing in this mark in
in these markets
uh going forward or last year and and
going forward
and i hopefully that will sort of give
you some idea about these markets
okay so if we look at the region uh as a
whole
this data comes from the singapore
business federation
uh it's a survey that spans across
well close to about a thousand companies
in singapore singapore
business federation takes the sample out
of about 24 000
companies in in singapore so you know
it's a fairly good representation
and we can see here what these companies
are thinking about
uh overseas so if you look at
the markets that most singaporean
companies
are exploring you know you'll see china
but we'll talk about the south east asia
region today
65 said that malaysia would be
the destination for them um
52 said that indonesia would be the
the destination for them and then the
next two countries that come up
uh is thailand and vietnam
uh also i think it's it's important to
note this
84 of the companies in singapore are
already engaged
in some form or the other within the
asean market
so you know a lot of the companies are
already tapping into
the the regional opportunities that
we're seeing here
okay so the top four company the top
four countries that sort of came out
of um the spf survey are
really indonesia malaysia thailand and
and vietnam and uh
what i want to do is maybe just share
with you
uh these seven data points and you know
they
they a pretty good picture uh about the
population
how their gdp per capita is uh what
their gdp growth is
e-commerce penetration which has become
increasingly important now
uh because a lot of the business now has
moved to to online
in these markets as well in fact in
these markets to a greater extent
than in singapore i wanted to share
the gi pc index which basically looks at
intellectual property so it gives you an
environment
a good sense of how secure
your ip would be in in these markets
and you know the risk of piracy and the
risk of copying and duplication and
counterfeits
is it sort of comes from there
the other area that you know i want to
talk about is just ease of doing
business so this
metric really takes into account how
how easy it is to deal with the
government uh to some extent
it looks at corruption bureaucracy how
easy it is to hire to open bank accounts
and you know your general day-to-day
operations as well
um so it's a global index and we'll
i'll share some data on that and you
know highlight what some of the key
sectors are
as well so
without further ado let me start off
with with indonesia
indonesia is well the largest
population in the asean region
but also it is fairly urbanized so 56
of the indonesia population already
lives
in in cities uh a large chunk of this
actually lives in jakarta and in the
neighboring cities
so that the market is fairly
concentrated geographically
in terms of total gdp per capita
uh it's significantly lower than
singapore so singapore gdp
per capita is 58 000. indonesia is only
at about four
000 having said that
there are there is a fairly healthy base
of customers that that span or consumers
that span across different socioeconomic
classes
so you know to the right of indonesia as
well relatively lower income than
singapore would
be a huge mistake
in the last year singapore indonesia has
been
relatively resilient to you know covet
there have been lockdowns
uh in fact you know we're seeing a surge
right now
in indonesia as well but business to a
very large extent has continued
uh you know partially this is because
singapore indonesia has started to move
towards
electronic manufacturing digital economy
something that's booming
in indonesia so with covid the impact
has been that you know the economy
shrunk by about 2.1 percent and you know
that's
that's not terrible if you contrast that
to singapore
singapore's economy is expected to have
shrunk by about 5.4
you know so indonesia was relatively
resilient
there as well um e-commerce penetration
in indonesia is is very high it's at 87
percent so 87 of the population is
already making
transactions on
online now
one of the problems does remain and
that's your gipc index
so corruption continues to be
quite a challenge in in indonesia uh and
you know the gray market is something
that that needs to be grappled with
in fact out of the 53
uh countries indonesia ranks
quite low it ranks at about 48 you know
compared to
singapore for example which ranks 11.
uh similarly for ease of doing business
as well so
the indonesian government structure is
such that there's a lot of power that's
delegated out to
or power is decentralized so there are a
lot of cases where
depending on your geographic rules a
jeff geographic location
different rules would apply in fact
one of the problems with indonesia is
that there's a lot of confusion on which
rules
to follow you know and that opens up to
uh
opportunities of corruption so you know
that
that is still a challenge uh having said
if you're looking at you know e-commerce
digital marketing fintech um
these are areas that are you know really
really booming in indonesia in fact in
terms of usage
indonesia is the large or indonesians
are
one of the largest vendors online
or largest users of e-commerce
in terms of the more established sectors
you know there is a lot of machinery
production
and electronics that happens in
indonesia
indonesia is an important part of the
global automotive supply chain so a lot
of the auto parts are made there
as well and you know tourism
historically has been an important part
but it's of course taken a hit
in in in the last year or so
uh but really the next frontier for
indonesia
seems to be sectors like fintech um
startups are are booming in indonesia in
fact it's one of them
one of the healthiest bed of startups uh
in this in
in the southeast asia region as well
the indonesian government is in the
final stages of
formalizing cyber security laws
use of personal data and things and i
think that that has
led to a lot of facilitation of the
growth of
the digital economy and startups
okay so um let's talk a little bit about
malaysia
next largely it's an urban population uh
of the population is urban it's higher
income
compared to indonesia so you know gdp
capital gdp per capita is about
10 000 usd of course still significantly
lower
than uh singapore but
malaysia has had you know relatively
good synergy between singapore and
malaysia and
we were talking about the need for local
partners in malaysia
that need is probably the lowest but in
the other markets
it's absolutely critical
malaysia has to a very large extent been
reliant on
uh you know global supply chains so
electronics is a healthy sector in
malaysia
but also largely that comes from the
automotive sector um
also petrochemicals um oil refining
uh that has been a very important happen
with petrol prices
uh you know falling um
it's it's been tough times for the
malaysian economy in fact
in the last year the economy given and
given covet
uh it's shrunk by about 5.6
uh you know so so malaysia has
seen somewhat of a slowdown that that's
happened
having said that e-commerce is something
that's very well established and you see
that again
you know 83 of uh the population is
already transacting online
uh gip gipc index is is better
uh so there's a little bit more
established rule of law
uh compared to indonesia
and ease of business while not
as as streamlined as
uh singapore uh it's still easier to set
up and operate a business
in malaysia you can see that from rank
you know so less lesser bureaucrat
bureaucracy
than what we saw in indonesia
in terms of what might be the growth
areas so
you know we're seeing a lot of
opportunities
in content creation that's happening in
malaysia electrical and electronics of
course continues to be a very important
sector
uh and we're we're seeing a lot of
opportunities in the education sector
and edutech
uh in malaysia so these are pockets that
we are
you know we're going to be seeing growth
in the next coming three to five years
as well
okay um thailand so
thailand has about half of their
population that
lives in urban areas
bangkok is really the main hub
but we also see pockets in chiang mai in
phuket you know so we are seeing some
decentralization
in in some of the cities as well um
thailand you know one of the unique
things about thailand is that despite
some of the political turmoil uh
business
continues to grow
you know so you know a lot of that
political thermal
doesn't doesn't tend to to spill into
you know things like manufacturing and
business services
now uh having said that last year
uh the economy shrunk quite
significantly see thailand basically
is very reliant on tourism um
automotive sector and and you know the
food sector
so these three sectors uh really drive
the economy now
tourism given covid uh you know
virtually
disappeared the automotive sector has
been slowing down historically
and we're seeing this across the asia
region so
you know thailand sort of suffered that
and that was exasperated by the covid
situation
uh fnb still continues to be one of the
healthier
and stronger sectors there so overall
there was a shrinkage in in in gdp of
about 6.1 percent so out of the
countries that we were talking about
today
um thailand actually saw
the largest impact from uh covet
um having said that the board of
investments which is the trade promotion
arm
uh of thailand is is exceptionally
pro-business and and so relatively
easier to
to deal with as well in terms of our
experience
in terms of gipc index so thailand ranks
lower than uh what you saw for malaysia
a little bit better than indonesia but
you know corruption
and and protection of ib is still
somewhat of a concern in thailand so it
ranks it's 45 out of 53.
and ease of business ranks at around 21
as well and this is something that you
know the government has been trying to
improve so this ranking has been
creeping up but you know the challenges
uh still remain
uh key sectors as i mentioned so
automotive tourism
you know electronics agriculture and
finance have been
areas as well but we are seeing fairly
robust growth in areas like
food processing medical and health care
has become a very big priority for
skyline certain so we're seeing a lot of
that happen uh
as well and you know uh
digital technology as we've seen in the
other regions is something that's that's
a big gaming
is something that is is quite big in
thailand and seems to be
you know thailand is one of or competing
to be one of the hubs
for for gaming and game development as
well
okay um the last market that um i wanted
to talk about is
is vietnam vietnam in terms of
urbanization
is is relatively lower than the
three that we talked about uh most of
the urban activity is
focused in ho chi minh hanoi and da nang
is is the new coming hub in in terms of
urbanization
also smart city programs are happening
around
dhana gdp wise
it's it's per capita it's about 3500 so
relatively lower
uh but again there are very significant
pockets of growth that
we're seeing there vietnam was the only
country in the region
that didn't shrink
where the economy didn't didn't shrink
in
the the kovid 2020 year
it's been fairly resilient to covet as
well so
number of cases and things have been
relatively small
they've been able to control the
situation exceptionally well
until recently so we've seen a little
bit of search that's happened
very recently and you know partially
cities have closed down ho chi minh
right now is you know
has social distancing norms hanoi on the
other hand
to a very large extent is is operating
you know
uh with with some measures but largely
it's business as usual
so there's a lot of promise there uh
for vietnam in fact it is considered
as in 2021 also as
one of the fastest growing economies now
vietnam
the big trend that's happening in
vietnam is um
this trend of privatization so the
government to a very large extent
you know and i'm talking about maybe
four or five years ago
uh controlled most businesses most large
conglomerates were
owned or controlled by the government
and until recently or or recently
vietnam has become a lot more open for
business and a lot more open to
private companies growing and a lot more
of fdi's uh
coming in in fact we're seeing a lot of
western companies as well as japanese
companies start to enter vietnam in a
very aggressive way
as their alternative to china where
it's becoming increasingly competitive
to do business
uh e-commerce penetration is at around
uh still still very high and this is
something that's also growing
in vietnam in fact vietnam is investing
a lot
on their id infrastructure as well as
regulations around cyber security and
interacting online
so you know this is really really set to
grow um
the gipc index is is still low
so it's it's 41 out of 53 so
those challenges remain but ease of
business ease of doing business i think
is something that
is still a challenge so uh dealing with
the government
in vietnam can be rather tedious and
it's very important to have local
sort of local expertise that can do that
so
company incorporation for example uh can
be quite difficult in fact
there are forex laws that
that that also can be quite restrictive
um historically the the main sectors for
vietnam
have been agriculture textile
electronics
um the new economy something as i
mentioned is
really growing uh vietnam
is you know taking industry 4.0 and also
agriculture 4.0
very very seriously so sustainability
has become an important topic and
an important theme in vietnam as well
okay so uh i'll quickly go through
this table which elaborates a little bit
more about
how company or what are some of the
boundaries around what companies can do
or foreign companies can do
so for most sectors
um foreign ownership is allowed
pretty much across the board uh in
indonesia
thailand and vietnam there are certain
conditions on the size of the company or
besides the investment
but it is relatively open uh
you know so we see the minimum capital
uh that's required
so you know so while foreign companies
can go in
having a local partner or a local
representative
is is still critical and you see that
here so indonesia you need a local
partner in malaysia you need one
in thailand you don't but it requires a
higher capital and the same goes for
vietnam
requires a higher capital investment to
happen
uh also in indonesia if you're going to
set up a company then a physical
address is very very critical
in malaysia thailand vietnam you know
there are workarounds
and it's not a mandatory uh requirement
local licensing local approvals with the
government uh are
invi are are required in fact central
government
and the provincial or the state
government you know
both would play a role there which makes
the process
a little bit tedious
in terms of currency controls most of
these con
companies do stipulate that business
done locally is done within local
countries
with the local currency indonesia has a
very strict law
on that um but
it is relatively easy to actually
repatriate funds to as well
um ip protection so i i mentioned that
all of these companies have fairly good
stringent ip laws in fact all of these
countries are
coming up with or have come up with
cyber security
um you know internet laws
as well but implementation is something
that
that remains
quite problematic uh
before i move on i'll talk a little bit
just about
so taxes so in indonesia the tax rate
and
you know taxes can be uh higher in
indonesia and malaysia
so you've got 22 percent in indonesia in
malaysia it's 24.
in thailand and vietnam it's 20 very
similar to what we have here in
singapore
but that differs a little bit um
and it's a little bit higher in most
countries most of these countries
except for thailand where it's it's
similar to singapore
as you approach market entry or setting
up
presence in these uh in these countries
it's very important to look at the
government incentives so not only
are there grants and incentives that
companies can
avail of in singapore but there are
programs in each of these countries
that invite investments and and you know
tax holidays
is one that's um that that's
that's very very common uh also in
all of these markets you do have uh
special economic zones
that offer you know further tax holidays
and subsidies on uh some of the
infrastructure costs and things like
that
so so very important to look into that
as as you go in
and you know all of these are members of
asean so most
uh trade related taxes and duties are
actually
you know they're virtually non-existent
okay so speaking of uh grants
just very quickly um i wanted to list
out some of the grants that you know
our clients look into so the mra grant
is something that
helps you to mitigate some of the market
expansion
activity you know in the initial stages
so
uh some of the research costs uh
and and you know promotion costs can be
mitigated
using the mra grant uh
if i remember correctly it's about 20
000 up to 25 20 000
or 70 of your costs
when you know you're working with
consultants or agencies
can be mitigated uh the m a scheme is
when companies are going through an
acquisition process
you can get up to 25 of the value that
you pay as
uh tax deductible
the igs scheme is a preferential tax on
revenue that you would
get from your overseas expansion
so the tax rate is is 10 rather than 20
uh for you know the the revenue or the
profits that are made
from overseas expansions uh and then
you've got an e-commerce program
which basically again has become very
very prominent
um it basically helps you gain online
presence
on the various e-commerce channels in
these countries
and lastly you know we've sort of shared
the link where you can look at
sg enterprises grants there
okay so um reaching the end of the the
presentation here but i wanted to sort
of
start wrapping up with this three-level
decision matrix um you know so once
you've once you start exploring overseas
expansion
the sg enterprise website has a great
internationalization toolkit
so it's in the form of a survey that
asks you about
your company history what your
operations are what your knowledge is
about the companies and
and your plans and it gives you an
assessment
on you know how ready you are
that then goes into the pre-entry
assessment we spoke about this you know
the market research understanding
your your customers competitors and
regulations uh and then immersing in so
yourself in the market and starting to
build
a local network and then you know the
third area is really making that
decision
on which mode of entry you'd want to go
in and and
start start sort of doing the groundwork
okay so uh lastly i wanted to just
share with you a very recent project
that
that we've done it's with a company
called billion bricks
this was under uh design singapore's
scope and frame program uh we worked
with
another company called tangible which is
a marketing consulting
firm and billion bricks basically
is an organization that is building
social housing or economic housing where
the roof of the housing is fitted with
solar panels so the energy generated by
the house
helps generate some revenue for the
people that
that live in the house and to a large
extent this is low-income group
and also sort of feeds back to energy to
the grid
of the local city or the local community
so it's
a mix it's a very it's a very
interesting design it's a mix of
you know social housing with energy
with uh you know solving the problem of
homelessness or low-income housing
uh billion bricks basically wanted to
start off a pilot project in philippines
and then go from there
and really build up the billion bricks
brand across
the region so uh our role
along with tangible uh the the partner
company that we work with
uh basically had to assess the
feasibility of the housing project
as as a start um also look at which
sites are going to be suitable so that
they'd identified four sites
and we evaluated which sites would have
the best business case
um and then of course figuring out
as was the case in step one who the
target customer would be
what needs need to be addressed uh which
segments to go after
and then you know coming up with a value
proposition and a pricing model
so what we did with billion bricks was a
four-part
process so we started off and we looked
at
the locations and we spoke with
the local residents there we did quant
interviews potential customer interviews
as well as you know looking at published
data
uh and we helped them basically identify
which business which site made the most
business sense
you know we then went in and because
this was housing
um we on we we
investigated what the customers wanted
so
what our project did was inform their
design decisions
you know so should it be a two bedroom
should it be a three bedroom
should it be two stories versus one
storey uh
what level of furnishing would they like
or what the layout needs to be and what
design elements need to be put in
uh that sort of happened in in in part
two
uh also we looked at what people thought
of
or what people expected the customers
expected from
a brand that was offering this this
product in fact
for billion bricks we showed potential
buyers the concept
and really did a market test on
receptivity
part three then was well now we
understood what the market needed
so ideation on uh
what are some of the alternatives for
them not only to build the project
but also to build the billion bricks
brand you know
uh starting off with philippines as the
first step
and then part four really was where we
gave in our recommendations
on which ideas are they should be
prioritizing
what model they should be going in with
what the offering should be
and you know what the implementation
needs to look like once the construction
or once the construction is underway and
it started
yeah so um i'm happy to talk about this
more if you have questions
that brings me to the end of my
presentation
um thank you japanese uh for bringing us
through this insightful presentation
um we are going to move into the last
segment of the day which is the q and a
um there are some questions that are
coming through the chat and if you have
any other thoughts from today's sharing
just feel free to keep them coming
through the q and a
chat function so let's just jump into
the
q a session okay so
um the first question that we have is
what is the local graphic design
expertise level in these countries
should be higher
sorry should we bring our experts or
hire local
uh you know i well
it differs a little bit but let's talk
about
thailand and indonesia now both of these
markets have a very very
vibrant creative industry and this
the skill levels uh for graphic
designers
is is quite high in fact
you know it in some cases i've been
quite pleasantly surprised
when we've seen our clients work with uh
some of the local designers
the question on should we be working
with singaporean
designers or sure or like the design
staff or should we be working with
the the in-country designers
there is an argument for local knowledge
and local understanding
uh you know as your deal depends on
whether you're dealing with local
clients
so there is an argument that says that
local
designers might have a slight edge uh
but then when it comes to technical
skills then i
i feel that singapore is at a stronger
position so it really depends on which
market that you're catering to
singaporean designers i think have a
more global orientation
but there is a lot of a lot of very high
skilled
uh labor that exists especially in
thailand
and indonesia thank you japanese i think
it's very useful information for our
design firms for attending this webinar
um i think
let's proceed to the second question um
okay the second question is
how will singapore companies entering
this market
compete with existing design firms in
foreign markets
given that the cost of living and labor
is cheaper
yeah so uh that is
is a challenge so i think it's very
difficult for
singaporean companies to play in
in the price positioning uh
sort of an arena having said that i
think singapore still enjoys
uh a very strong brand
in terms of quality technical
capabilities innovation
so i think singaporean companies
can use that to to mitigate some of
the price sensitivity uh also i think
singapore
companies can position themselves as
facilitators
for regional or global growth
so you know which is when you'd want
your clients to work with singaporean
companies if you're looking at a global
brand
then let's work with singaporean
companies if you want to stay local
and you're designing for local then
maybe the local companies and the cost
advantage
sort of comes in so there are a couple
of
value propositions there already
and then of course it really depends on
execution and what the companies are
doing
so um thank you japanese this is just
another question which
related to the earlier question so um so
are the local businesses more open to
local design brands
or foreign design brands
um we
well we're seeing a shift in the market
i think
we are seeing a shift where consumers
are now
shifting back to local brands so if we
had had this conversation
a year ago i would have said well the
global brands and the international
brands
you know still still trump but we've
started to
see a shift where well i don't want to
say local brands but probably
localization of brands has become very
very important
even if it's a singapore company to
localize that brand
and offer local design options is
something that i think more and more
customers have started to go down that
path
useful information uh germany so i think
we can
uh the next question it's uh more about
uh spire research
so has your company assisted any design
related
singapore firms expand into southeast
asia countries
if so what are the type of companies and
can you share some challenges that they
might experience
while entering other markets then
there's another part to the question so
maybe you want to take these two
questions first
sure well i think the billion bricks
example that i
i just spoke about so this is um
it's an architecture firm or a house
design firm slash product design firm
that is addressing uh homelessness
or you know in some cases it's portable
homes but in the case of philippines
which is where we're helping them grow
uh it's it's really sort of coming up
with the housing community and then
building their brand as a developer
as uh an ecological social developer
uh this is a project that we've done
very very recently in fact we're just
we're just wrapping that up in terms of
the challenges that we see
well i think
lack of good reliable data for decision
making
continues to be a challenge this
particular project was in the
philippines
and philippines this is a unique problem
but we see this in other in other
countries in the region
indonesia thailand uh as well
um you know so there
there's that also a huge dependence on
local networks uh is something that's
that's going to be critical so
having local staff and this company that
we work with eventually started to grow
their
local team in the philippines i think is
critical also
so i mean apart from all these
weaknesses that you've seen i mean
what are other strengths that you think
the companies that you work with
as well as singapore companies have in
this southeast asia markets well so you
know
i mentioned well these markets in terms
of opportunities are
they're more larger they're more diverse
they're more vibrant
uh you know if we've got good ideas that
can be effectively localized and there's
a clear opportunity for singaporean
companies
also when you're working you know and
that's here i'm talking about
singaporean companies selling to
[Music]
local consumers when it comes to b2b
and singaporean design firms trying to
sell to to
local businesses you know then sort of
singapore brand
uh singapore's ability to protect ip
uh and just a global know-how i'm gonna
throw in one more which is technical
technical skills
uh you know these are sort of strengths
that singaporean companies can actually
go in with
okay so there's another related question
to what you said earlier
so um uh what is the focus on this three
southeast asia
countries in particular any thoughts on
other religions such as
china or europe
that's an interesting so a lot of the
work that spire does
our focus is on the southeast asia
region which is why you know i'm sharing
this
i think the other the other market that
um is very prominent very popular among
singaporean companies is china
you know so we're seeing a lot of growth
there um
japan we we don't see as much in
expansion happening i think it's more of
the other way around it's japanese
designs japanese companies and concepts
coming into the southeast asia region
um and again europe so i'm sorry we
don't do
so much work in in europe but it is a
relatively
a lot of the growth is happening in this
region despite all the negative numbers
that i was showing you
you know there are a lot more
opportunities for growth here
in the southeast asia and asia region as
compared to europe um
i'm sorry i haven't been able to answer
that question no no worries but it's
good to know that i mean there's a lot
of growth for design firms in singapore
to you know
explain in the countries that you
actually referred earlier in your
presentation
so um so what would be some like uh
typical mistakes that people make
uh tend to make while entering a new
market i think this will be very useful
for our design firms
yeah okay um
in in my company because of
our parent company they do a lot of
joint ventures and a lot of
mergers and acquisition sort of projects
and
we've basically seen
where in these cases the plans can be
quite elaborate
but the integration of two firms doesn't
happen
you know that's that's sort of one
mistake that we've seen
and it comes down to being able to work
with local staff
and local customers and having sort of
basically localization
of your acquiring brand or acquiring
company
um when that doesn't happen effectively
you know we we've seen disastrous
results
the other one that i think i will
highlight again is
related to understanding the local
customers so one of the mistakes that
we've seen singaporean companies make is
going in with the fallacy that they know
the market
or that they know better than the market
you know so oh we're going to go in with
this
brilliant singapore design singaporean
design it works really well here
or you know we've seen it with food for
example and we'll go in and we'll change
customer behavior and we will be able to
influence them and convince them into
using our
products um
doing that without having a very good
understanding of
the customers uh and that flexibility
that
that the company would need to localize
to the market rather than the other way
around
um you know that that has been a
challenge
and it can lead to very very slow or no
uh customer acquisition and
increasingly this has become
more and more difficult it's become more
difficult to convince local customers to
buy
products that don't fit with the local
tastes you know the
the that whole international
internationalization westernization if
you can call it
it's losing its charm in the recent
couple of years
okay um then um since um
um we just have a short time so we'll
just quickly take the last two questions
jeff nick
so the the second last question would be
could you share a bit about what type of
singapore-based organization
could have to bring the expertise to
sorry uh could you share a bit about
what type of singapore-based
organization
uh have to bring uh what kind of
expertise to
interest the companies into overseas
market
oh um i mean
i think we're seeing well
that's a tough one um i think
let's say indonesia so we see this
vibrant
startup hub uh coming in so i think
singapore going in with global access
and of course funds
is something that i think is a nice
match
uh the other areas
around market testing
or commercialization of certain designs
i think is is another opportunity where
you know singapore companies
would have a greater access globally or
regionally to the market
compared to some of these smaller local
firms yeah that's sort of the tool that
that i can think of thank you so much
and
this last question is based on your
experience um so
how well do architectural practices
fare in terms of expansion in asean
region
interesting so i'm just reflecting if
you can give me i'm reflecting on on
some of the conversations that i've had
uh being an architect i have somewhat of
a perspective because
i end up speaking to a lot of the
architects that are working here
um i think
there there is there has been an avenue
where
singaporean architectural firms have
worked with
local developers or international
developers
um and they've brought in
the singaporean brand if you will in in
in into the value proposition you know
so the fact that you're
a singapore company has helped win
projects
um but it comes at a very big cost
because you know i think that one of the
questions earlier was
well just it's so difficult to have an
office
it's so expensive to have office and
staff and designers
being based here so we've also seen the
singaporean companies start to offshore
some of the design work
into their
in into their local country offices you
know so um
one of the firms that that we were
interacting with very closely was doing
projects in india
doing it was a singaporean company
singaporean brand
architectural firm that was winning the
projects but a lot of the design work
was happening in thailand
or increasingly started to move to
thailand because of
uh cost pressures you know so that's the
kind of thing that that
that that we're seeing the singapore
brand is important but it's very
expensive to maintain
all of the infrastructure here thank you
so much
and then there's one last question that
just came in
i hope you can take it um so any
suggestions on how people can approach
culture fit between two companies
across two different markets and any
pointers on doing this for the
c-suite and the actual operation teams
ah
as far as possible my
my recommendation and you know this is
in some cases it's feasible in some
cases it's not
is to hire local to have local teams
i think is is very very critical um
apart from that i think facilitating as
much interaction as possible
with senior management and that could be
one culture
with the working level staff is is
another one in fact i mean i would argue
that used to be tougher to do in the
past because you had to travel
but now you know using platforms like
zoom
um you could argue that it's actually
become easier for senior management
to spend time with with the local staff
you know you and on both sides on
both the management in singapore and the
local staff they've both
learned how to do it digitally now
i think that has to be accepted uh so
yeah so i think you know it's it's
become easier rather than more difficult
thank you very much abnet for the
engaging conversation
and taking for and taking all the
questions um so
i hope you enjoyed today's webinar and
we would like to thank uh you for
joining us this afternoon
should you wish to revisit to this
discussion a summary of the key
notes will be shared with you via email
along with the relevant links on how you
can reach out jab need
please help us with a post event survey
which should appear on the screen now
has the leftmost qr code the
presentation slides will be shared upon
the completion of the post event survey
and if you're a singapore designer or
singapore and uh
sorry if you're a singapore designer or
a design enterprise racer in singapore
interested to find out more about dig's
support and programs for the local
design industry feel free to approach us
to build our email address industry
design singapore.org which is uh the
rightmost qr code
and also we like to take this
opportunity to thank japane for the
wonderful sharing today again and to all
attendees
we hope you found the session inspiring
and meaningful we hope to see you at our
subsequent events
thank you and see you soon thank you
bye-bye thank you
you